The square root example has to do with specifying the properties of the results
of a computation of a function. We might also consider situations where
the effect of a particular operation is to change the attribute values for some
class. How might we do that? Well, let's consider the example of a bank account.
And has an attribute which is the current balance and has operations for
deposits and withdraws. We might wish to guarantee that the balance,
the current balance reflects any deposits that are made and
any withdrawals that are taken out. How might we express such a constraint?
Well here's an example, if we have a deposit operation in the account class,
that takes a real argument. Which is the amount being deposited and
as the sanity check we make sure that the amount is greater than 0,
that's the precondition. We might try to express the post-condition
with something like saying the balance equals balance plus the amount.
However, remember that the OCL is a declarative language. An equal sign here
means equality it doesn't mean assignment. So what we're saying with this
as the way that it's written is the balance equals the balance plus the amount.
Well, that can't be the case. All right, that doesn't make sense. Fortunately,
OCL has a mechanism for allowing us to express these sorts of situations where
we're changing, changing values. And that particular mechanism is,
consists of an @ sign followed by the, the word pre.
And what that denotes is the value before the operation executed.
If we don't use @pre than what we're seeing when we express balance or
deposit is the value afterwards. So we can express the post-condition
this time correctly by saying that balance equals balance @pre plus amount.
That is, we take the previous ba the previous balance,
add in the amount being deposited and we get the new balance.
Looks like an assignment segment, but it's really an equality.